it's interesting that our culture has
become
cancer our culture has become culture
war the culture war is our culture
what we are interested in talking about
in mainstream television is
shock content and hating each other cnn
what what is cnn's main goal what has it
been for four years
complaining about donald trump trump is
gone okay let's try tucker carlson
and it was really funny frank luntz the
famous pollster tweeted at brian stelter
when he tweeted this
maybe try covering the issues instead of
some guy
and then brian was like maybe you should
watch the full segment because i'm no
dude
talk about the issues i'm not interested
in any of these individuals necessarily
sure we can call out bad behavior when
it's particularly egregious
but our culture is nothing now for the
most part other than
here's who i don't like meanwhile you
know china's culture is
we're expanding into the south china sea
we're building military bases on the
atolls we're building fake
we're building artificial islands to
hold weapons
and you know what's really scary donald
trump ordered what's called an elephant
walk
well i believe it was trump's trump
administration where we sent bombers and
fighters to guam
and we have them go along the runway to
show how powerful we are
and did you know that we were treated we
were treated our forces from guam
when they were supposed to be doing that
elephant walk to show how powerful we
are where do we treat you know why
because china's military capabilities
could have wiped out the entire fleet
before they could get off the ground
talk about a sign of weakness for the
united states now what do we get
wokeness in the military the chief
diversity officer
to make sure that everybody is being
treated properly gender neutral testing
and now all of a sudden
we gotta get rid of that because the
women aren't passing god have equal
outcomes
women can't get promoted if they can't
pass the physical exam therefore we
gotta change the physical
physical exam so they can pass more
that's what we're worried about in this
country
bill maher said it and it is an
excellent quote we are a silly silly
people
china they're as serious as a prison
fight that's what he said
i think we we really need a second
coming of christ
because elon's not getting it done if
elon musk can
can engineer our our exposure to mars
and build
i am not technology it can prove i know
it can preserve our species he's the
engineer that can help us preserve
going to mars is going to hell it's not
enough like
he can't if people don't rally around
elon we need
jesus like we need to like hold on hold
on god bless
these associations yes sir mars is not
hell
what do you think the what do you think
the colonists the early pilgrims and
colonists thought about land crash
landing
i'm being a bit exact i'm exaggerating
what do you think they thought about
getting on a boat for three months with
a deep with a one in five chance of
dying
to land on a shore where there's no food
no water no shelter nothing
first of all they believed that there
would be food and they believed that
they would bear water because they knew
they were going to be on earth
first of all and they knew how to hunt
and where they were living already they
were already fending off the land
i am not going to mars you there's
nothing you can say to convince me
i don't want you to go to mars but guess
what so so
you're saying that people who left
europe to come to the new world
had the ability to farm and hunt yeah
dude so wouldn't the people going to
mars have the ability to use the
technology sent there beforehand to
produce food and water and shelter i
suppose if there's water and food and
sunlight
okay temperatures there's comparing mars
to the new world in the 1500s is insane
it's not insane it's insane
people who would be going to mars are
going to have technological advancements
on their side
is there oxygen there yeah there will be
yes it's in the water under the surface
okay it's in the ice turn mars into
earth
you got to melt the ice and then i will
go no there's no magnetosphere i think
they might maybe
sounds terrible right you don't
understand the people who
don't understand yeah these big wooden
ships the technological advancements
that allowed them to actually make it
across the atlantic
thousands of miles these were very brave
people
no doubt who didn't know what they were
going to encounter and there wasn't
going to be
food or shelter in fact thanksgiving
they almost died because they had
nothing to eat and they were saved right
so you so what i'm saying is it is yeah
substantially harder to be a pioneer to
another planet
you need to go to mars the alternative
hypothesis around thanksgiving is is
like
look at us show off this abundance
of food by the way before we go to mars
we're going to be sending supplies and
technology
so that the people who finally arrive
will be able to build large ecodomes
with food and supplies that will last
them for years consistent amounts of
supplies coming in
okay i understand a lot of people are
scared of this because it's a one-way
trip for the most part
and you may die on a red planet i'm not
saying that it better be
green by the time i get it it's not ever
going to be it could be i thought that's
what you're just telling me that
it's gonna be green you can seed bomb it
there's no magnetosphere whatever
prometheus
water on the planet because they can't
keep maintaining it there is it's just
it's just a light one there there's
there's there's no way to maintain an
atmosphere it's dissipating
are you trying to talk me into it or out
of it bro i'm trying to explain to you
that there's no atmosphere that we used
to be we used to have people on this
planet
who are willing to sacrifice in the name
of of
reaching new heights of challenging
themselves and finding freedom
and now now we have a bunch of people
who instead of saying i'm gonna move to
the middle of nowhere
and build my own building do what i have
to do they're saying i want the
government to regulate
all of the jobs i'm not religious at all
but i'm with you on that but not on
christ i mean i think that we need this
like this belief in
i don't know if it's god or what but
like this unified belief in
in the universe structure you know that
that jesus was one of the guys that was
like i'm tapped he tapped into it
the basis of spirituality is to get
outside of yourself
whether it's a belief in god an
afterlife
community service helping other people
doing charity work
get out of yourself our culture today is
designed around being in yourself
wallowing in yourself and presenting
yourself as the biggest
victim that there is in order to get to
the top of the victim
standings that's the problem with our
culture today bro people just need to go
play frisbee
we're talking about a lack of of self a
lack of well not a lack of self it's
nothing but the self
we're talking about a lack of purpose
meaning community
friends goals go outside
bring a frisbee with you to the park and
say you wanna play frisbee you wanna
just throw a frisbee around maybe hang
out with some people
it's actually really fun and and they
don't throw a ball back and forth
but people need to go outside and
actually
do something instead people are
recoiling they're retreating they're
hiding
now i think i'll i'll tell you what i
think one of the biggest problems
problems we've got as a as a culture
certainly china doesn't have it
their people in china they're they're
calling what china is doing
neo-colonialism
because the people in china are leaving
they're taking what money they have
they're moving to other countries
they're emigrating and now we're seeing
large chinese communities emerging in
many other countries it's neocolonialism
it's not happening because the chinese
government isn't is ordering people the
chinese communist party is ordering
people to go and take over anything like
that
no no no it's just people who are in a
very crowded country
trying to find a better life just like
we saw with europe hundreds of years ago
but now there's planes there's trains
there's boats and many of these people
have the resources
they find their way to another country
set up communities and they grow in
their work and i'll tell you this
the american dream is alive and well
there's just too many people in this
country too egotistical to actually work
towards it
when i worked for american eagle
airlines in america
it's american airlines regional uh
airline there was a group
that referred to themselves as the
filipino mafia
no joke that's what they called
themselves and it was a large group of
filipino immigrants who were working for
the for the airport
working for the airline and they all
basically
worked 14 or you know 16 hour days every
day
there was one guy he was like in his 50s
they
forced him to take a two-week vacation a
two-week paid vacation
and he was freaking out and complaining
saying i refuse you can't make me do it
they said actually we legally are
required
to make you take a two-week vacation he
didn't want to do it because a one-week
vacation is only 40 hours paid
when he worked 80 hours a week and you
know why because he was
he came to this country he worked 80
hours a week and every penny
went into making his children's lives
better this is a guy
that was in the philippines and said i'm
going to move to america and i am going
to work my skin to the
bone no matter what it takes for that
american dream and his dream
was to work for 10 bucks an hour every
single day
because he knew would make his
children's lives better
where's that at where are the people
today that are saying
i will do anything i can a lot of
immigrants who come to this country
absolutely believe that i've watched it
you look at the people who come from
china the united states what do they do
they cram their families into small
apartments that are cheap
they work themselves to bone they make
money and they give their children a
better life
now we have a lot of people in this
country a lot of a lot of progressives
mind you
yeah obviously i'm biased in that regard
who are just demanding the government
give to them
meanwhile they're the ones who are
claiming they're the party of immigrants
and it's like well why don't you
actually take some advice from them
and work hard to succeed that that's why
i i look at the mars thing
yeah i get it mars is difficult mars is
scary there are a lot of people who want
to go to mars
i don't know if we need to go to mars
it's necessarily i think a solution to
our problem i think maybe a space
station is probably better
and then maybe finding you know a
long-term vessel of some sort i don't
know how we do it our technology is not
there yet
a martian colony can be fantastic for
the development of new technologies to
make everyone's lives better
and the people who ultimately decide to
go there are going to be going on a very
dangerous journey where they will
probably die
the the likelihood of death might be
like one in five like it was for those
who went from europe
to the new world granted we have new
technology
and we'll have a lot of fail safe so
maybe it'll actually be a bit less but
boy will it be lonely
but these are the people who are saying
hey man i'm down to do it
now while we've got all these people
signing up for elon musk's mars trip
there was that mars one project what it
was called
and thousands of people like i wanna go
to mars i wanna go to mars and none of
them were
healthy enough to actually do it where
are the people
you live in new york city you live in
minneapolis and you're like man this is
terrible
antifa's taking over the government
they're getting funding now they're
shooting people not non-stop we're all
depressed
bro why don't you get up go outside
start planting some flowers start
planting some corn
why don't you like i you know what you
know what i've been looking at for a
long time it's like
moving out to the middle of nowhere on
purpose to expand and to build something
because when i sin that doesn't work you
know what i do i don't go
this is why i hated working for other
companies you go to the boss and you're
like
hey i see this problem and they say too
bad i don't care i can't i can't do that
i can't sit there and look at a problem
that won't be solved so i'll say okay
i'm going to leave
and then i'm going to do it on my own
because if you don't know how to run
this system i'll figure it out for
myself
where are those people where the modern
pioneers who are like i'm gonna move
to the middle of nowhere start a company
and revive this dying town
instead they're in their dying towns
complaining to the government to do
more to protect their jobs and it's both
the left and the right i think they
exist but they're drowned out in a sea
of noise
especially online with when everyone has
their own no
anybody journal anybody online who
believes that they can do it is doing it
online is the land of the icants what i
have found
interesting is that our country used to
be a country of i can
i can sail across the atlantic and start
a new life i can explore the west coast
go to oregon go to the seattle
him say it i can do that you mean i can
walk there i can walk and if you
couldn't to the west you didn't have
access to a newspaper to tell everyone
how you couldn't do it you just didn't
have access
now you got twitter for free and now
you're about to but the problem the
problem is is that the american
spirit the american dream if there is
actually one american dream is i can
yeah all these other folks right now
that we're talking about these are the i
can't
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you